des détecteurs thermiques pour scanner
les voyageurs qui est la ville des
conseils pour les nouveaux arrivants les
autorités chinoises ont augmenté la
surveillance du cornât virus apparu
récemment à one une grande ville du
centre du pays et la chaîne un plan de
prévention de contrôle strict du virus
explique ce porte parole
et elle collabore avec l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et les pays de la
région
l'épidémie s'est déclarée dans ce marché
de fruits de mer et démons vivant qui
était désinfecter et fermé des
commerçants et des clients ont éprouvé
de graves problèmes respiratoires causés
par un nouveau coronavirus de la même
famille que l'astra ce qui a fait des
centaines de morts en 2002 2003 de one
le corner virus est ensuite propagé à
deux autres villes chinoises et
maintenant à trois pays de la région la
chaîne vient par ailleurs de confirmer
que le nouveau corona virus peut se
transmettre de numéro un ou une autre et
que des travailleurs de la santé ont été
infectées faut se méfier à partir du
moment où la transmission de personne à
personne
selon l'efficacité de la transmission il
faut c'est sûr envisager des mesures de
santé publique plus importantes pour
contenir les pires jusqu'ici le virus a
infecté plus de 200 personnes a causé
trois décès et sept patients sont dans
un état critique
c'est un taux de mortalité plus bas que
celui du strass qui lui a atteint 10%
mais les spécialistes estiment qu'on
sous-évaluent bil'in des cas d'infection
en chine et qu'il va rapidement
s'alourdir
aux états unis on a commencé à vérifier
l'état de santé des passagers dans
l'es30 pas qui assure une liaison
directe avec one au canada une campagne
d'information pour les voyageurs
débutera cette semaine dans les
principaux aéroports du pays
présentement au canada ya pas lieu de
s'inquiéter outre mesure parce que
l'épidémie elle est concentrée dans la
ville de rouen dans la petite province
centrale de chine là ya pas de vol
direct qui viennent de nous rendre vers
le canada ici quelques jours ce sera le
nouvel an chinois et on craint
maintenant que le déplacement massif
d'individus dans le pays favorisent la
progression de l'épidémie
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal